whoa
whoa
hey
hey
wake up
there's a bud like can sitting in there
and he passed clean out that's just for
me
he'll go home
the horse knows how to get home
418.
he's eastbound on
bogue
b-o-g-u-e
we got a drunk amish guy passed out in a
buggy
staley and bogue road he just turned
eastbound on bogue
and i yelled at the guy when he rode by
there's a bud light can sitting in the
damn buggy and i hit the side of the
buggy and hollered at the guy he's
passed clean out he slumped over
no i mean i'm yelling whoa whoa whoa and
no
i'm gonna see if i can get in front of
him and slow down
421
51.
you're 18 seconds
we might have it stopped nope
disregard
he just rammed it into my car
hey stop your horse
stop your horse
stop your horse
get your horse
grab your horse
okay grab the horse so it doesn't do any
more damage please
it's rammed it into my car already
watch yourself he's coming around to
grab him i don't want him backing up
go ahead all right get him over here
how old are you i'm 21. 21.
for right now until i can determine
on who you are
let me see your hand
i'm going to detain you all right all
right
i saw
yes where
all right come on
418 that's before
just leave him right there
leave him right there
no just hang on
just hold him don't let him move
you start 29 for a head injury
for the driver
what's going on in your pocket you got
anything
[Music]
right
i got to get him in here first then i
can move
six three two four three
repeating victor adam four six three two
four three
i got around him and had him stopped
and he stopped in the road and then when
i got out
he went to go around me and just rammed
it right to and he's got busted his head
and fell out in the damn ditch
what's up with the paws
sometimes
oh he's passed out cold we're running
the siren i'm banging on the side of the
buggy
he's drunk as shit there's beer still in
there
i didn't know i wasn't home i didn't
know he was doing any of this
i had he was stopped
he hasn't moved i pulled mine up he's
it's all over the back oh shoot maybe
puke i don't know
and i started walking around the corner
of the car to grab the reins
and that's when he fucking took off
did i stop here man
you couldn't catch him
every time you get the side of him he'd
freaking speed up
you